all right well should we get on with the
next pick all right do you wanna you
want to pick it or slide it you can go
for a man meal gun it doesn't really
matter
it matters to me
it's not gonna matter
i see a tea
it's me there you go you're saved i
guess okay thank you thank god joey can
carry the podcast after i finish talking
about okay so
um so how i tried to pick this i tried
to pick this i tried to pick music
and artists and songs that really
defined every stage of my life so this
might be
a little bit random are we gonna see
peppa pig the full album
why don't you mean diaper music like is
he bitsy spider
so
bob the build soundtrack it was a cold
summer night at the age of three
i decided it was honestly you know
twinkle twinkle little star [ __ ]
banger thomas what can i [ __ ] say
there's an absolute banger soundtrack
bob the builder that that opening was
like
all right ashley put it up ashley put it
up go on
i i this this [ __ ] will not
leave my record
yes yes
okay okay so
um so i guess i'll go through it from
right from left to right sorry i'm sure
you know all of these i don't know the
one i don't know this one you don't know
that one that's that's the uh that's one
of the two japanese ones on the edge i
know three japanese ones so
uh top left is muse
yeah yeah yeah
uh we've got we got music
we've got muse and then we have bradio
and then we have the kooks or is it no
it's just cooks right
um we have the killers we have michael
jackson mk we have mj come on uh we have
zutumayo uh we have daft punk arctic
monkeys and obviously the uh fully
cooley sounds i don't know why i thought
that was ben's still off for a while
oh
it's not does not look that bad
i was like damn still
all right all right so where where do
you want to start off uh who cooks i
like them that much okay so
okay so the reason i put the cooks there
right all cooks like is it the cooks or
is it just cooks
i'm obviously a bad
is it the cougars okay that's that's
what i thought and it was this is
specifically inside in the inside out
the album because it's one of the few
albums i actually have listened to all
of the way
um and the reason i put the cougs in
there is because they are originally a
bland from brighton right
and got to represent that homecoming no
no no no exactly but like i did not know
this yeah i did not notice for the
longest time right but listening to
their music
and listening to this album especially
before i found out they were from
brighton i was just like [ __ ] this
literally epitomizes the brighton vibe
and like what it is like being a
teenager growing up in brighton right it
literally like epitomizes the vibe of
like going to like this random [ __ ]
beach party or just going to a random
house party in england sometimes that
privileged lifestyle you know you know
you know you know it's uh and uh you
know you know trying to pick up chicks
or just you know just
heavily binge drinking or whatever right
like if i had to pick a show for example
a tv show that epitomized british
teenage life it is the in-betweeners
right if you've seen the in-betweeners
i've not seen a more accurate
representation of what it is to be like
growing up
uh growing up at around like college age
which college age is kind of like high
school age right
and to me
the kooks is
if you listen to this album it is
growing up in brighton college age so
about 16 to about 16 to 18 years old um
and that's why it's on there uh i feel
like i only know one song
i think there are like two big songs on
there there's like naive and like yeah
so nice
it's really
she's like really like drawn out yeah
like every every word i think and i
think it's like she moves in her own way
that's the other side of that song
[Laughter]
that one that one is like burned into my
head it is because like all the time in
the uk that was that was the song that
like introduced me to the kooks but like
i feel like those are like the two most
like naive and she moves in her own way
as like like the two most poppy songs in
their album because definitely their
later albums they got like what they
like way go away like way on the poppy
side of things like they were kind of
like kind of like a maroon 5 in that
sense like you know you compare like
early maroon 5 albums uh to like the
later maroon 5 albums and it's just like
okay this is like night and day yeah
this is not in there this is like okay
there was a point where i like maroon 5
and then there's this like billboard 100
maroon 5. you don't know this she moves
like jagger
yeah yeah you don't like sugar
but i i will stick up for like early
maroon 5. i i think early moon 5 was
actually pretty damn good